bonjour à la houppe et remercie de
répondre à nos questions le pdg du
laboratoire pfizer saluent ce matin un
moment historique
votre réaction le fait qu'il ait une
coordination européenne c'est une bonne
chose puisque nous la gt3 permettez moi
de vous reprendre je parle là du du
royaume uni le pdg de pfizer part d'un
moment historique
concernant l'approbation par le royaume
uni du vaccin à 13h biotech le pdg de le
ferait et rassurer et satisfait parce
que ilaina un marché important
mais moi j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur
le principe de la médecine qui ai pris
ma menons nos serré et j'ai peur qu'on
est ce qu'on tombe dans un risque
d'emballement sur les médecins parce que
souvenez vous nous que le 8 octobre
dernier
l'europe l'union européenne avait acheté
l'équivalent d'un trait de traitement de
cinq cent mille patients à 2000 euros
par traitement de rennes des civils et
trois jours après l'om est ce par son
étude solidarité disqualifié
complètement ce traitement
donc j'ai peur que on engage l'europe et
en particulier les deniers des citoyens
européens vers une catastrophe
catastrophe économique une catastrophe
sanitaire parce que ce traitement qui
est à base d'arn messager n'a encore
jamais été utilisée sur le terme
vaccinale ont l'utilisent dans les
thérapies génique pour le traitement de
cancers
de 2,2 au grade effectivement de ce
vaccin finder biotech arn comme le
laboratoire moderna également alors que
d'autres vaccins sont sont différents
justement le laboratoire pharmaceutique
parle c'est le laboratoire qui part
d'une efficacité de 2 95% quid des 5%
restants justement quid des 5% restants
cuite de cuite de ce qu'il va se passer
parce que les bénéfices à court terme
c'est les fameuses 95% mais il ya une
zone d'ombré à long terme on ne sait pas
comment on va réagir
l'organisme des gens vaccinés souvenez
vous que la france est quand même un
pays où on a peur des vaccins
souvenez-vous du vaccin contre
l'hépatite b qui a créé une polémique où
il y avait des maladies neuro
dégénératives comme la sclérose en
plaques et le préfet de l'époque bernard
kouchner l'a suspendu a fait un
moratoire
un vaccin ça s'élabore en plusieurs
années et là il ya un emballement un
emballement médiatique
un emballement politique l'impression
qu'on est dans un déluge makina pour une
maladie où 99% des gens infectés s'en
sortir en inde m je parle des gens
infectés
je ne parle pas des gens contaminés
parce que l'europe est une mosaïque
l'europe et de mosaïques on l'a vu dans
la distribution des masques dans la
qualité des tests parce que nous avons
en france des tests mal calibré avec
beaucoup de faux positifs c'est pour ça
que nous avons tant de gens infectés
vous parlais justement de la méfiance à
se faire vacciner notamment en france
selon un sondage ifop pour le jdd très
récent 59% des français ne voudrait pas
se faire vacciner comment est ce que
vous expliquez cette cette défiance
justement est justement par rapport à
l'europe et à sa stratégie commune est
ce que c'est un frein à cela c'est une
défiance normal la médecine la médecine
c'est quelque chose là métier section de
simple c'est une relation entre le
patient et le médecin la médecine c'est
pas une décision européenne
c'est pas une politique de santé commune
parce que là on est en train de rentrer
dans une politique de santé commune où
l'europe va prendre le pas sur nos
ministres de de la santé nous avons tous
nous sommes face à ce virus
l'europe est face à ce virus et l'europe
réagit d'une manière différente la seule
seul avantage que je vois dans cette
dans cette tentative c'est d'harmoniser
et de faire en sorte que nous posions
par 450 millions de personnes pour avoir
des prix des prix compétitifs et surtout
une égalité de traitement mais on voit
qu actuellement les prix n'ont pas été
négociés puisqu'on l'a vu pour le raid
m6 vire le prix imposés par gilead a été
le prix américain
donc j'ai peur qu'on qu'on arrive encore
avec un échec
qu'on soit face à un mur merci alain
houpert d'avoir répondu à nos questions
en direct sur arte france je rappelle
que vous êtes sénateur
les républicains de la côte d'or et est
médecin radiologue